We have already worked through
some examples in which X was a
random variable with a given
PDF, and we considered the
problem of finding the PDF of Y
for the case where Y was the
function x cubed or the function
of the form a/X. What
both of these examples have
in common is that Y is a
monotonic function of X.
In this case, Y is increasing
with X. In this case, Y was
decreasing with X. It turns out
that there is a general
formula that gives us the PDF of
Y in terms of the PDF of X
in the special case where
we're dealing
with a monotonic function.
So, let us assume that g is a
strictly increasing function.
And what that means is that,
if x is a number or smaller
than some other number x prime,
the value of g of x is
going to be smaller than
the value of g x prime.
So, when you increase the
argument of the function, the
function increases.
To keep things simple, we will
also assume that the function
g is smooth, in particular that
it is differentiable.
Then we have a diagram
such as this one.
Here is x, and y is given
by a function of x.
It's a smooth function, and
that function keeps
increasing.
Now, because of the assumptions
we have made on g,
we have an interesting
situation.
Given a value of x, a
corresponding value of y will
be determined according
to the function g.
But we can also go
the other way.
If I tell you a value of y, then
you can specify for me
one and only one value of x
that gives rise to this
particular y.
So, the function g takes us from
x's to y's, but you can
also go back the opposite way
from y's to values of x.
And the mapping that takes us
from y's to x's, this is the
inverse of the function g.
And we give a name to that
inverse function,
and we call it h.
So, h of y is the value
of x that produces a
specific value y.
Let us now move on with the
program of finding the PDF of
Y. We will follow the usual
two step procedure.
And the first step is to
find the CDF of Y.
So we fix some little y,
And we want to find the
probability that the random
variable y takes a value in
this range.
When does this happen?
For Y to take a value in this
range, it must be the case
that X takes a value
in this range here.
Values of X smaller than this
particular number result in
values of Y that are less
than or equal to
this particular number.
So, we can rewrite the event
of interest in terms of the
random variable X and
write it as follows.
We need to have x less than
or equal to h of little y.
But this is just the CDF of
X evaluated at h of y.
We now carry out to the second
step of our program.
We take derivatives of both
sides and we find that the PDF
of Y is equal to the derivative
of the right hand
side, the derivative of
the CDF is a PDF.
And then the chain rule tells
us that we also need to take
the derivative of the term
inside here with respect to
its argument.
And this is a general formula
for the PDF of a strictly
increasing function of a random
variable X. How about
the case of a decreasing
function?
So, let us assume that g now
is a strictly decreasing
function of X.
So, we might have a plot
for g that looks
something like this.
What happens in this case?
We can start doing a calculation
of this kind.
But now, how can we rewrite
this event?
The random variable Y will
take a value less than or
equal to this number little y.
When does this happen?
When the value of g of
x is less than y.
And that happens for
x's in this range.
So, this is the set of x's for
which is the value of g of x
is less than or equal to this
particular number y.
So the event of interest in that
case is the event that X
is larger than or equal to h
of y, which is 1 minus the
probability that X is
less than h of y.
Because X is a continuous random
variable, we can change
this inequality to one
that allows the
possibility of equality.
And so this is 1 minus the CDF
of X evaluated at h of y.
Now we take the derivatives of
both sides and we find the PDF
or Y being equal to, there's
a minus sign here, then the
derivative of the CDF,
which is the PDF.
And finally, the derivative
of the function h.
Now in this case, g is a
decreasing function of x.
So when x goes down,
y goes up.
When x goes up, y goes down.
This means that when y
goes up, x goes down.
So it means that the inverse
function h is going to be also
monotonically decreasing.
Since it is decreasing, it
means that the slope, the
derivative of the function
h is going to
be either 0 or negative.
And so minus a negative value
gives us the absolute value of
that number.
So we can rewrite this by
removing this minus sign here,
and putting an absolute
value in this place.
Of course, in the case where g
is an increasing function,
when x goes up, y goes up.
This means that when y
goes up, x goes up.
So h in that case would have
been an increasing function,
so this number here would have
been a non-negative number,
and so it would be the same
as the absolute value.
So using these absolute values,
we obtain formulas
that are exactly the same in
both cases of increasing and
decreasing functions, and so our
final conclusion is that
in either case, the PDF of Y is
given in terms of the PDF
of X times the derivative of
this inverse function.
Let us now apply the formula
that we have in our hands for
the monotonic case to a
particular example, where y is
the square of X, and where
X is uniform on the
interval 0 to 1.
So the function g, in our case,
the function g is the
square function.
Now, you could argue here that
this function is not
monotonic, so how can we
apply our results?
On the other hand, the random
variable X takes values on the
interval from 0 to 1, and
therefore the form of the
function g outside that range
does not concern us.
Over the range of values of
interest, the function g is a
monotonic function.
So, what is the correspondence?
y is going to be equal
to x squared.
That's the g of x function.
And when that happens, we have
the relation that x is going
to be the square root of y.
This tells us that the inverse
function, h of y, which tells
us what is the particular x
associated with a given y, the
inverse function takes the
form square root of y.
So now we can go ahead
and use the formula.
The density at some particular
little y where that little y,
belongs to the range of values
of interest, x things values
between 0 and 1, so y also takes
values between 0 and 1.
So over that range, the density
of Y is the density of
X, which is uniform, therefore
it is equal to 1, times the
derivative of the square
root function.
And the derivative of the square
root function is 1 over
2 times the square root of y.
As you can see, the amount of
calculations involved here are
rather simpler compared to what
we would have to do if we
were to go through our
two step program
and work with CDFs.
All that you need to do is
essentially to identify the
inverse function that given a y
produces x's, and write down
the corresponding derivative.